c'est ce que redoutent de nombreux pays
européens et l'irlande est le premier à
prendre la décision
le pays a décidé de re confiné sa
population pour une durée de six
semaines lors d'une allocution télévisée
le premier ministre irlandais michael
martin a annoncé le début de ce
reconfirme ans à partir de mercredi
minuit dans l'effort de suppression du
virus nous avons déjà mis en place ce
qui est probablement le régime le plus
strictes d'europe
de ce fait nous pouvons constater que
ces restrictions ont été efficaces pour
ralentir la croissance et la propagation
du virus
toutefois comme le montrent les chiffres
au quotidien ces restrictions à elles
seules n'ont pas suffi à réduire de
manière significative les niveaux
d'infections
ainsi si nous avons ralenti la
propagation du virus cela n'a pas été
suffisant et d'autres mesures sont
maintenant nécessaires
le gouvernement a décidé que les preuves
d'une situation potentiellement grave
survenant dans les semaines à venir sont
maintenant trop forte
par conséquent pendant une période de
six semaines à partir de là mercredi
soir minuit
le pays tout entier passera au niveau 5
du cadre de vie de kobe de 19
tous les commerces sont essentiels
devront donc fermé leurs portes les bars
et les restaurants ne pourront désormais
proposer que des services a emporté les
mariages sont maintenues avec une
restriction de 25 invités et il sera
interdit de se déplacer à plus de 5
kilomètres de chez soi
le gouvernement irlandais a tenu à
laisser ouvert écoles et services de
garde d'enfants
pour le premier ministre il est
nécessaire je cite que l'avenir de nos
enfants et de nos jeunes ne souhaitent
une autre victime de cette maladie
michael martin admis qu'il s'agit sans
doute des mesures les plus strictes
d'europe
mais avec ces nouvelles restrictions le
gouvernement irlandais espère sauver les
fêtes de fin d'année et permettre aux
citoyens de célébrer noël correctement
même son cloche au pays de galles qui a
choisi de se re confiné pour une période
de deux semaines à compter de vendredi
18h et rim entre le vendredi 23 octobre
et le 9 novembre
tout le monde au pays de galles devra
rester chez lui stay at home
cela signifie qu'il faudra travailler à
domicile
il part tout cela sera possible les
seules exceptions étant les emplois ou
le travail à domicile n'est tout
simplement pas possible
les entreprises non essentiels du
commerce de détail des loisirs de
l'hôtellerie et du tourisme fermeront
leurs portes comme elles l'ont fait
pendant la fermeture du mois de mars
les centres communautaires les
bibliothèques et les centres de
recyclage seront fermés les lieux de
cultes seront fermés pour les services
normaux autre que les funérailles où les
cérémonies de mariage si plusieurs pays
du continent européen ont déjà durci
leurs restrictions il s'agit dans le cas
du pays de galles de la mesure la plus
dure instauré dans le pays depuis la
première vague de kovy de 10,9 au
printemps dernier